well some residents facing evictions say
the new moratorium announced this week
really just isn't enough
a local organization helping immigrant
workers held a rally today
joe moeller shows us what organizers say
needs to happen
people who were already evicted and
others who are now facing eviction say
they want the governor's help people
came here
outside the grant sawyer building spaced
out to send a message
arriba the las vegas workers center
organized the rally they say the
governor's moratorium implemented this
week does not do enough
they say they want a number of things
changed including a closure of eviction
courts and a moratorium on utility
shutoffs during the holidays
many of the people here were immigrant
workers organizers say not enough is
being done to protect them
when this pandemic starts i lost my job
and after that i lost my apartment and
asking
him to help families like me because i
am single mom
of three kids and they are suffering
a lot so i'm asking him to help us we
spoke to many people who were evicted
and many who are worried about
electricity being cut very soon here
people say immigrant workers need more
protection financially and from the
virus
the organizer we spoke with from ariba
is worried that if something is not done
soon here more people will end up
homeless reporting in las vegas joe
moeller 8 news now